disturbs the out of me is that
after I got better CNN MSNBC all these
mainstream news things are mocking me
for taking horse medication they're
saying he took horse medication he took
horse dewormer like literally taking a
drug that's on the World Health
organization's list of essential
medicines literally taking a drug that's
been prescribed billions of times taking
a drug from that was invented by the guy
who won the Nobel Prize for inventing
that truck I got better quick nobody
cared that I get better quick all they
cared was I didn't get vaccinated what's
the best way to shame him let's point to
this one thing that he took and mock
this person for taking this foolish
medication they even changed the color
of my face on CNN they thought they were
CNN and CNN was huge CNN is the news CNN
is a gigantic corporations they have big
building the whole deal giant sign they
didn't understand that this podcast is
10 times larger than them